what a ramirez's banana plants are
drying up for months there's been no
rain in this region of Nicaragua many
wells are running dry climate change is
affecting the traditional changeover
between wet and dry seasons farmers in
the second poorest country in Latin
America are feeling the impact but there
is a glimmer of hope for a 1-over
Amira's with this device you can
thoroughly dryer harvest
thanks to this 1,000 watt solar panel
she no longer has to leave her produce
out in the elements to dry that protects
her harvest from unpredictable weather
conditions I used to have to watch out
for hens going after my produce and
worried about it getting dirty that's
not the case with a solar dryer I just
pop it in close it up farming community
in a neighboring area is also using this
technique their solar dryer has a
significantly larger capacity the
farmers can dry about 450 kilograms of
corn beans and rice in just two days
they use a hydrometer to determine when
their produce is fully dry that's
valuable information Purdy Elson cuenta
por ciento de me program once lost about
half my crop when we had two weeks of
rain during harvest
I packed the beans and sacks without
noticing that they weren't properly dry
that's why Alta sacado
the solar dryers are manufactured here
close to the capital Managua the
Austrian firm Kona supplies the
components it also holds the patent
Cecelia Cruz is their contact in
Nicaragua more than 80 such units are
already in use throughout the country
our system allows us to use solar power
rather than lock fires to dry cocoa
beans in the Walla Walla area for
example the forest is being recklessly
cut down to provide wood for the drying
process since no one thinks about
reforestation the trees will soon be
gone one of the most powerful units in
the country can be found at the
University of Lyon researchers here use
solar energy to make food like banana
chips that's good for the environment as
well as for the farmers in Nicaragua it
means they can secure a higher income
for their produce